how did you land your your best client
in your best year we always say it's
literally all about timing you could
literally say hey you're hiring to a
hiring manager and they might have 10 AE
roles and go yeah we are actually
looking for an agency it's really good
timing or you do the most creative
campaign to them and they're like take
me off your
mailing I genuinely don't think there's
a right or wrong to it I will always say
right time right person if you catch
them right at that moment and also just
follow up so important I even think
sometimes a good followup is just bad
timing on this one John A lot of the
time they'll actually come back and say
even if it's a no go it is actually bad
time at the moment Kate but reach out to
me in January and give you like a time
and at that point I'll put it in my
diary reach back out to John